alright no suspensions for Chris long
for smoking marijuana during his playing
career but he admitted on the Dan
Patrick show yesterday he smoked a lot
and this is no surprise it's amazing to
see the people who clutch the pearls and
say oh oh it's horrible the Chris long
smoke marijuana look a lot of guys smoke
marijuana and the way the testing system
is set up it's easy to beat the test and
long made a great point yesterday the
point is this you know when to stop
smoking marijuana because the window on
the annual one test only opens on April
20 you stop mid-march the problem is
what do you do from mid-march to the end
of April to deal with your pain to deal
with any other issues the marijuana
helps you with you end up taking
prescription drugs you end up drinking
you end up doing things other than
smoking marijuana that may be less safe
for you overall big picture long-term
than smoking marijuana
so his ultimate point is the NFL does
need to change this and I admire him for
having the courage to admit it yeah
because there's always going to be that
cluster of knuckleheads out there that
want to shake their finger at him
without realizing the world has changed
dramatically folks people smoke
marijuana now oh by the way they always
did but now it's legal in far more
places than it isn't and the NFL is
finally catching up and I think we need
more guys like Chris Long come out and
admit that they did it after their
career ends stupid to do it during your
career but I think more guys need to
admit that they did it afterwards so
people realize this is what guys do to
deal with the pressure the stress the
pain the discomfort right of being an
NFL player yeah no doubt about it and I
do I mean you said it I think that the
number of NFL football players that
smoke marijuana is much higher than
people realize I mean you know I'm gonna
say 50% of the the locker room is you
know a pretty consistent group of
smoking marijuana okay then I would say
there's another 20% in the locker room
where I would go they're the type of
guys that maybe smoke let's say once a
week or once a month or something like
that right so it's very prevalent in an
NFL locker room one okay because of all
the things you mentioned the you know
the pain management the way it makes
guys bodies feel everything like that -
hey just like every other worker and man
in the world who likes to have a beer or
you know some wine
you know after work or whatever it may
be NFL football players want to do that
too but they don't want to mess with
alcohol alcohol I mean there's really
just nothing worse for the fit for the
physical body and the muscles than
alcohol so players to maybe relax or get
that buzz at the end of a day or
whatever it may be
yeah they would rather smoke weed then
drink liquor to where they go oh I had a
few drinks and then you pull a muscle
the next day because you're dehydrated
or whatever it may be from that liquor
so again I think it is great by Chris
long and in the Millennial culture as
you know Mike right now popping pills is
a thing I mean it's a huge thing in our
country and you know to me this would be
another way to kind of get some of those
younger millennial guys because I know
in the NFL some of the younger guys are
still pill poppers that's what they did
in college and because it was the cool
things to do the uppers the Downers
whatever it may be and I think if they
had marijuana at their disposal that
they'd be less likely maybe to partake
in some of the pill activities hey the
best news of the week that the NFL is
allowing a study to proceed and allowing
the doctors to decide whether or not
marijuana should be used as pain
management the biggest step away from
removing this from collective bargaining
and we want to get something in return
from the Union before we take away the
marijuana prohibition if it's the right
thing to do it's the right thing to do
and at a minimum it's the right thing to
do to start this process hopefully they
conclude the process with marijuana
being something players can use for pain
management what your what's that smile I
sneeze sneeze they didn't know if you
saw me god bless you thank you it's okay
to sneeze here's the thing we did the
airing of grievances earlier let me just
say this generally when you have to
sneeze sneeze don't do that thing where
you hold the sneeze in you can literally
cause a cerebral hemorrhage by doing
that sneeze okay you have to sneeze
sneeze
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports